foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
selective depletion of cd45ra expressing
cells to enrich antigen specific T cells
for immunotherapy
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual cancer research and immuno
oncology week
I am Angelina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
miltony biotech for more information
about miltony biotech please go to
miltonybiotech.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask the
question box and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Sanya
Sharma research technologist in the
laboratory of clinora M Rooney
for a complete biography honor speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr Sharma you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thank you for tuning in and
today I'll be presenting our work in
enhancing and enriching entities in
specific T cells for immunotherapy and
whereby we have developed an approach to
do so
these are my disclosures and I would
also like to say special thanks to
miltoni biotech for their invitation and
this opportunity to present our work
here today
so we don't know about additive cellular
immunotherapy it's really using immune
cells to fight of disease and today we
will focus on virus specific T cells or
vsts which do so by recognizing viral
epitopes presented on target cells and
in doing so we utilize virus specific T
cells in post-transplant infection or
against viral malignancies for
post-transplant infection it is used
against viral reactivation and infection
where I've listed all these viruses as
you can see here Epstein Barr virus CMV
adenovirus PK virus or many more other
viruses this is mostly used in
allergenic donor derive VST setting and
next against viral malignancies we know
that 10 to 12 percent cancers or whether
oncogenic viruses and I have listed here
the five most oncogenic viruses as you
can see here and over the past few years
there have been um
new developments and effective treatment
against some this viral associated
malignancies in both autogen autologous
and allergenic settings
so today we'll really focus on viral
malignancies and virus specific T cells
used against those
so the various trees that we use against
viral meningitis can either be
engineered vsts which really means that
they have transcending T Cell receptor
whereby the transatic result targets a
single epitope on single Target and
design however the downside to this is
that if the tumor downrigue is HLA or
there is an antigen loss in the Target
cell then the effectiveness of this
Transcendent TCR expressing viruses
specific T cells is going to be
diminished
so what we will focus on today is virus
specific T cells with Native T cell
receptors whereby the psts can be
expanded to multiple epitopes targeting
multiple antigens in target cells
and this started with this initial study
where EBV specific T cells were used to
Target ebb positive post-transplant
proliferative disease ptld and were
quite effective ever since then there
have been subsequent studies as I have
listed here against EBV HPV MSP gamma
virus where these have validated the
effectiveness of virus specificity cells
or their potential with Native tissue in
autologous settings
so in using this viruses specific T
cells against virus Associated
malignances you can either use them as
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes which we
know have been used in HPV however the
problem with using tubes is that it is
really difficult in manufacturing and
accessing these tumor inflation in
lymphocytes the next way you can use
this utilize this viruses specific T
cells is by isolating and generating
them from peripheral blood which we know
have been used in EBP MSP comma virus
so however but then again there is this
problem that manufacturing from
peripheral blood are still limited by
difficulties in expanding these virus
specific T cells from patients in
autologous settings especially because
these um T-cells that are circulating in
the peripheral might really be rendered
dysfunctional in suppressive tumor
microenvironment or it could just be
that they are low infrequency in
circulation
so today in this webinar we're gonna in
uh in terms of three main points we're
going to talk about the objectives the
first one being understanding the
obstacles to successful manufacturing of
antigenous specific T cells in
immunotherapy
the next one will be highlighting the
effects of City 45ra depression which is
our approach and I will expand on it in
a bit and finally understanding the
effects of our approach and its
implications in immunotherapy
so let's begin with understanding the
obstacles as I mentioned before that
when we are generating cells from
peripheral blood in persons there could
be problems where these cells are just
low in frequency and are dysfunctional
so in order to study this obstacle we
utilized our model of Epstein-Barr virus
specific T cells or ebbsds as we call
them in our clinical trial against ebb
positive lymphoma
we know that 30 percent of Hodgkins
lymphoma Epstein-Barr virus positive and
as you can see here that the ebb
positive lymphoma biso expresses the
latent viral antigens as shown here and
we can generate T cells that would
Target this EBV positive lymphoma P cell
by targeting these EBV viral antigens as
shown here and these cells are called
EBV specific T cells and these are the T
cells that are expressing native T cell
receptors specific to these EBP antigens
and how we do so is basically just in a
graphical representation you draw the
blood from the patient then you harvest
or isolate these peripheral blood
mononucleases as we call them pvm cells
these pbmcs are then stimulated to the
EBV pep mix which are really overlapping
peptide libraries of the four ebb Target
antigens that I mentioned earlier with
pain results in selective expansion of
the T cells that are responding to that
EBV antigenous stimulation in more
details so you have your PBM says then
you provide the CBP peptide libraries or
EBV pep mixes the cells which recognized
as a Viv antigen and are then gonna be
stimulated and expand these cells are
then further stimulated with the antigen
presenting cells or the core stimulated
cells to specifically expand these cells
that responded then you get our your EBV
specific T cells these evb specific T
cells are then further transferred
adaptively transferred into the patient
with them so that they can Target and
call Ebb positively informal cells
and so when we looked into our clinical
trials the EBV specific T cells we
noticed that we had 27.5 manufacturing
failure and what that really means is
that we noticed that 27 of the lines
that were proclaude from the persons
either failed to expand or even if they
expanded they just lacked EBV and design
specificity
so we further looked into this some
phenomenon of a manufacturing failures
and we also noticed this manufacturing
fillers in a HPV specific T cells which
has also been generated in our clinical
trial under Dr Carlos chamos and his
clinical trial
so for our ebb specific detail since we
saw 27 manufacturing failures we went
and looked into the lines that we have
generated the ebb specifically cell
lines that were generated from the
percent what you're seeing here is a
waterfall plot where we're looking into
the interference gamma released by the T
cells in response to evb antigenous
stimulation by Alice potasse on the
y-axis is the number of T cells or
interference gamma from spot forming
cells which for every 100 000 ebb
specific T cell that secreted into
friend gamma when they're stimulated
with EBV antigen on the x-axis each line
represents a percent line that was
attempted to generate
and you can notice here that this dotted
line which signifies as less than 50
ssc's are the lines that only secret
that only secreted 50 cells that are
secreted in different gamma over 100 000
ebb specific T cells and you can see
here that a lot of the lines have really
low antigen specificity below 50 is
performing cells this is tells us that a
lot of our lines do lack and design
specificity when we specifically looked
into these lines you can notice here
that a lot of the lines
they just do not grow we know that and
then some of the lines they do grow but
then they still lack EBV specificity
so because we see that they grow and
they lack ABB specificity we looked into
our lines phenotype and as you can see
here that a lot of our lines even though
they did have CD3 positive T cells you
can see that a lot of them have a very
high frequency of cd56 positive 33
negative and K cells so this tells us
that in addition to expanding City
positive T cells we are also expanding
other cells like anchor cells in our
culture which could be one of the
reasons why our cells lack ebb antigen
specificity so from our observation
we're able to identify two major
problems then the lines some lines do
not proliferate but when the some lines
do proliferate they do still lack ebb
antigen specificity and that there is
presence of unwanted or non-ebb specific
by standard cells
which led us to then ask can we
specifically expand and design specific
T cells from peripheral blood
so we know that the pbmc is composed of
mileage cells and lymphoid cells and
what we are really interested is in
expanding these T cells residing in
lymphoid compartment to generate our ebb
specific T cells
and further looking into the T cells we
know that results can be divided
characterized and divided by various
surface marker expression and one of the
most commonly associated marker is cd45
and we know that the knife cells and the
stem cell like memory cells reside in CD
photograph are a positive fractions the
memory cells reside in City 45 are a
positive fraction however the terminally
differentiated memory cells which are
supposed to be High effective or
short-lived reside in Array positive
fraction again so we know that the arrow
positive has the memory cells and we
know that after viral religion infection
resolution the T cells reside in memory
compartment and then this cd45 are a
positive fraction really con includes
this knife ts-70 effector memory which
is not of so much interest to us in
generating memory residing entries in
specific T cells
however cd45 are a positive PBM says
also comprises regulatory cells B cells
and NK cells which are also not the
cells that we want in our culture when
we're generating T cells for our
patients
so with this we rationale that
if we're going to deplete these cd45ra
positive expressing pbmc subset it will
decrease our and cancer population and
bystander cell frequency and enrich
memory residing T cells which will then
result in enhanced enrichment of our
memory residing ebb specific T cells
so with that we hypothesized that
selective enrichment of memory T cells
will enhance the antigen specificity of
our EBV specific T cells
so for that what we did was we took our
PBM CIS as I mentioned before then we
selectively remove the ra positive cells
from the pvmcs and
then resulted with this memory increased
are already depleted previous
this already depleted pvms is where then
stimulated with ebb pep mixes to
generate our memory in raised already
depleted ebvsts which for now will be
calling them array depleted ebvsts are
already ebvsts
and um we did this cd45 ra depletion by
utilizing human City 45ra micro bits
available from military biotech and how
this magnetic leveling works is that
these um humans City 45 antibodies
attached to these magnetic micro bits
any cells that is expressing cd45ra when
when incubated with this micro bits is
gonna get attached to this microwave so
when you run these cells through this
main column in attached to this magnetic
platform every single cell that is
attached to this microbead is then gonna
get stuck in the column however then we
get this Iliad which is depleted of
array positive expressing cells which
are stuck in the column so with this
technique then you get this illutail
cd45r80 Bluetooth cells which is highly
increased in memory cells
and we did test the system with both
cd45ra depletion or just by selecting
cd45 Ro positive cells and using these
cells for our culture
so
now that we know the system and we
started doing this first we wanted to
know how effective is utilizing this
cd45ra micro bits in order to remove
cd45 Express itself as you can notice
here that um we for this toner we had
about 62 percent of our city 45 area
positive cells in whole pbmcs and by
utilizing this multani biotic micro bits
you can notice that it was highly
effectively depleted to just leave 0.03
percent of cd45 are a positive cells in
our already depleted pvmc fraction
which is more clearly sewn and there's
some graph for all the other donors
combined and you can see that we are
indeed able to achieve highly successful
and clean depletion of audio positive
cells we're utilizing this technique
in addition as I mentioned before that
um presence of NK cells was also one of
the problems and uh that and crystals do
reside in are a positive reaction as you
can see from the start plot in the lower
part of the slide where you see that um
there was about 7.3 percent of NK cells
did indeed were cd45 are a positive and
crystals and the depletion of Arya
positive does also deplete and kissels
in our resulting already depleted pvmcs
as you can notice here
so now that we know that we are able to
effectively deploy cd45ra positive cells
and um understand that lack of antigen
specificity and or diminished
proliferation is one of the obstacles to
successful manufacturing of antigenous
specific T cells in immunotherapy I want
to further touch another point of
highlighting the effects of this R
education
so now we did our education our ultimate
goal is looking at characterizing the
functionality of our T cells so first we
wanted to look into the proliferation of
our T cells where we compare the
proliferation of holy bbsts shown here
in black with the ritability bbsd son
here in red and we were able to
demonstrate that ra depleted bbs3s do
indeed demonstrate higher fold expansion
compared to what we observe with whole
ebb specific T cells over 16 days of ebb
antigenous stimulation and these were
all done in haldi ebb positive
seropositive Health ABB said a positive
healthy donors
so now that we know that the cells are
able to proliferate our ultimate goal
was looking into the entire
so we looked into the antigen
specificity in our educated dbsts and as
shown here by D for our reticulated
dbpsds and W for whole EBV specific
results you can
observe that or a depletion really does
significantly enhance the frequency of
antigenous specific T cells as denoted
by interference gamma releasing two
cells
compared to what You observe with whole
ebb specific T cells in these three
representative donors
when we look into the overall donors you
can also see that in the donors that we
have looked so far we do significantly
enhance the overall antigenous
specificity of our our educated
University is compared to a whole
different
safety cells
now that we know that it enhances the
interfriend gamma we then wanted to look
at the fully functional T cells by
looking at interference gamma and tnf
Alpha by our intracellular side again
sustaining acid as you can see here that
on the top panel you are looking at the
in different gamma and tnf Alpha some
secreted by the whole ebb specific T
cells and in the Bottom by the array
depleted ebvsts and you can observe that
are a depleted dbpsds with EBV
stimulation do in these secrete
significantly high frequency of
polyphoon high frequency of interference
gamma and tnf Alpha T cells compared to
what You observe with whole ebb specific
T cells is also further so on in this
graph where you do see that statistical
things difference in the increased
frequency of poly functional cells as
defined by endocrine gamma and tnf Alpha
positive cells in our assay
so now that we know that it secretes
more interference gamma such as multi-nf
Alpha we really wanted to look at the
Target antigen specific cytotoxicity and
for that we did on chromium release
assay and as you can see from our
personal specific license graph that our
educated dbsd is shown here in red do
demonstrate enhance frequency enhanced
percentage of killing against ABB
positive Targets on in the left compared
to what we observe with holy BB specific
T cells and I would also point out to
that that to the right of that graph you
can notice that when you the when these
T cells are incubated along with the
non-ebb Positive targets they do not
kill showing that there is no autologous
killing of the target cells
so next we really wanted to look at the
phenotype and the frequency of the um T
cells that are comprising our EBV
specific results as you can see here for
our educated dbsts in red that they do
indeed have a higher frequency of CD3
positive diesels and decreased frequency
of CD3 negative cd56 positive NK cells
in our culture
and interestingly we were also able to
identify that with our origin of
literary vsts we observe this more
balanced ratio of CD4 positive T cells
and CDA positive T cells compared to
what highly security positive to self in
our holy BB specific Jesus though we did
not delve much further into what this
means and how this affects the our T
cells there have been various
Publications and there have been various
research in the past year over various
years to indeed so that the presence of
City for positive T cells does help in
the efficacy and potency of our T cell
products in immunotherapy and we do
believe that this is a balanced ratio of
CD4 and cd8 does indeed contribute to
the increased um and in specificity and
potency of our T cells
so now I've so far so new that with City
45 redepulation we are able to
demonstrate compared to Holy bbsts that
demonstrate enhanced proliferation
and is in specificity Target antigenous
specific cytotoxicity and increased
frequency of poly functional cells
so now that we know that they do have
high frequency
I would like to go back to the same
graph that I saw earlier about T cells
and point out to this fact that there is
also this stem cell like memory in the
city 45 very positive action which is
really these cells which have been
identified and so on to have long-term
persistence proliferation and stem cell
like functionality so there is a concern
that is the removal of this area
positive cells diminishing our long-term
potential and functionality so we asked
how about long-term functionality and
Persistence of our array depleted EVP
specific T cells
I needed it into do so first we looked
into the phenotypic subsets of our T
cells and when we compare the decentral
memory of subsets in our whole and
already polluted dbvst is as you can see
here that there was no statistically
significant differences in the central
memory population in our whole versus
irregular TBB specific T cells
additionally what we did observe was
that our
origbe specific T cells do actually
demonstrate lower frequency of Team
three calories and lactic positive G
cells compared to Holy bbsters and these
are the T Cell markers that have been
associated with diesel exertion in
immunotherapy and when we just look into
the overall
frequency it is very clear in this graph
that already depleted DBS is to indeed
have lower frequency of this existing
micro expressing T cells compared to
Holy BB specific T cells
then after we know that there is this
some phenotypic differences we did want
to look into the long-term proliferation
so in order to look into that long term
in vitro proliferation we provided
simultaneous antigen stimulation every
day seven after day nine and looked into
the proliferation of our T cells as you
can notice here that with the with each
antigenous stimulation
is in red do continue to proliferate
with much higher expansion for than what
you observe with whole EBV specific T
cells
and now that we know that they do
proliferate looking into their antigen
specificity you can notice here that are
a depleted bbsts do indeed demonstrates
higher frequency of antigen specific
diesel than what you observe with whole
ebb specific T cells and even though it
decreases by day 30 you can notice that
it is still higher than what you would
observe with holy BB specific T cells
so now that we know that they are
persisting for longer period in which or
we wanted to do the ultimate test of
testing in Vivo so for that we
established a EBV transform visual line
which are rambisa line transformed first
with ebb and subcutaneous tumor in our
NSE mice murine model after the tumor
was established we then adaptively
transferred our whole pbmcs ebvsts are
evst is generated from rag politic
fpvmcs and then measure the tumor
as you can see here so the tumors were
also labeled with gfp firefly luciferous
so we can also identify their
bioluminescence and as you can see from
this bioluminescence Imaging that around
day 12 when the whole ebb specificity
cells is still demon demonstrate quite a
bit of tumor the mice receiving already
polluted dbbsds have heavily diminished
bioluminescence this is also
corroborates with our measuring of the
tumor volume as you can see here from
this graph for Holy BB specific research
shown in Black compared to control
group in um green and the mice that
received array depleted ebvstown here in
red do demonstrate that Rapid Control of
the tumor that you cannot observe with
the Holy BB specific T cells even though
both group only bbsts in black and
redbsters in red do go on to clear tumor
at the end you should be able to notice
this some early Rapid Control of tumor
by our originality dbsts which also is
um related with this decreased
metastatic tumor burden in this S1 in
this panelist image you can notice that
um our device that received a depleted
dbvsters lack that metastatic tumor
which is absorbed in holy bbsters and
this rapid tumor control will be
important in um patients where we are
really trying to control high
physiological tumor button
so now that we have shown this in our in
which model and in our individual model
with our ebb cell positive and healthy
donors we really wanted to go to our
ultimate goal of translation what about
in percent pvmcs
so in order to look into that we
generated whole and already depleted
ebvsts from patient pbmcs were enrolled
in our clinical trial and as you can
notice here that our educated dbvst is
do indeed demonstrate High antigenous
specificity compared to what You observe
with holy Beauty specific T cells
and over where different patients that
we looked into we were able to see the
same set of median and I would like to
specifically point out person two
percent five and percent six where you
can appreciate that in where they lacked
any antigen specificity and we were not
able to generate these EPB specific
digital lines now we are able to
successfully generate EBV specific cell
lines without our education approach
because we know that we can indeed
restore entities and responsiveness and
successfully generally be best in
persons that previously failed to grow
so in addition to this increasing
entities in specificity as I mentioned
before high frequency of NK cells was
another problem in our culture so when
we looked into the NK cells you can sort
of hear that the ra depleted vbs3s do
indeed decrease the
um the resulting and case of frequency
in our EBV specific results compared to
what You observe in whole ebb specific T
cells
so with this um observations we were
able to find this clinically feasible
approach in generating 14 dbv specific T
cells and since the military cd45 area
microbeads are clinical grade they are
GMP compliant and can be used for
clinical translation
um there is only barely like 20 percent
sale loss during the actual process and
that can really be overcome by the
enhanced proliferation of our educated
ebbsds so it is highly feasible even in
person where sometimes you might have
low number of total pbmcs count in this
presence
and in it isn't too slowing that we were
able to generate highly increased
antigen specific T cells for Ebb
specific T cells cd45 are depletion is
also applicable to generating virus
specific T cells specific to other
viruses like visibly HPV agent or bkb
and here today I will just show you an
example of us generating virus
specificities also specific to Adeno and
vgv and you can see here that compared
to whole array depleted vsts for both
Adeno and vgv demonstrate higher
frequency of antigen specific T cells
just still demonstrating that this
platform can be applicable to generating
viruses specific results
foreign
feasible platform for generating
clinically potent vsts and as so we have
successfully translated this approach
into two of our clinical trial against
um using ebb specific T cells as we have
mnd our ebvst clinical trial against
refractory relapse EBV positive lymphoma
in autologous setting and also in a
second clinical trial where we're using
chimeric antigen receptor with modified
ebb specific T cells against lymphoma in
allocating in addition to that we have
also adapted this approach certificate
approach in generating multivirus
specific T cells again HPV vcv agent and
bkb and post allergenic stem cell
transplant
so just to give an idea of how ourselves
and how amending this into the clinical
trial in our autologous setting clinical
trial has been going on here I'm just
showing you the 12 ebb specific T Cell
lines that we have generated from
presence so far and for 100
manufacturing success including percent
one which was a manufacturing failure to
begin with and now we have a highly
antigenous specific T cells
and uh to see how these cells respond in
person here I'm showing you an example
of uh one of the lines pressing four so
this was the entries and specificity of
the line that we generated and as you
can see here that over um the different
weeks after infusion of our T cells we
can see that there is an increase in the
number of T cells that are secreting in
different gamma in response to BB and is
any stimulation in the patient pbms
during their follow-up which is really
exciting and in addition to that we also
see an increase in the frequency of T
cells specific to non-ebb lymphoma
antigensity thus demonstrating epitope
spreading which has been correlated with
um success of its eliminate therapy and
we observe this in our
this implants that we have infused and
however how our cells are going to
behave and how they are going to respond
is really going to depend on bring
further long-term follow-up analysis and
historical comparisons with previous
cohorts
so with this second part I have shown
you and highlighted the effects of cd45i
Education you can see that we can
selectively expand and enrich entries
and specific T cells by our approach of
CD 45-hour education which really
results in successful manufacturing of
memory residing and design specific T
cells and also is a highly feasible
clinical platform in virus specific T
cells generation
so now next moving on to our final point
of understanding the effects of our
approach and its implication in
immunotherapy
so obviously it is needless to say that
we have indeed created this platform
which is highly applicable to generating
virus specificity cells and as you have
seen from our data that it can enable us
to generate highly potent T cells from
patients and healthy donors which have
high potency in vitro and in Vivo and we
will be able to observe it based on our
clinical trial responses
in addition to all these effects I would
also like to point out there's some
little side of extra bonus that in using
this allergenic third party donor T
cells you also get this extra bonus of
reduced gvsd and alloy activity as we
know that
um there have been various Publications
there have been various groups who have
indeed done cd45 education to remove
highly reactive T cells in use in using
in immunotherapy so our approach does
also Aid or provides an effect in that
um so with all these effects and with
all these benefits we also do know that
our approach did not only restore
antigen responsiveness in person but
also overcome our manufacturing failure
so basically just removing this cd45rx
pressing subset enhance the frequency of
antigen specific T cells telling us that
it is really not the
reasons of but the lack of antigen
responsiveness in our whole EBV specific
T cells and by removing that array
positive population we are able to prove
we're able to let the memory resigning
entities in a specificity cells to
respond
which tells us that there are these
various cellular subsets in the whole
ppmcs when we generate our T cells what
is a limited therapy can have different
effects within each other and we know
that over the years various groups have
studies this kind of effects and have
published and just to name a few there
have been publication specifically
cultism functions there was also there
are also been Publications with the T
Cell T Cell interaction where um
clevenov and his group had shown that
there is like an interaction between
knife T cells and memory T cells which
results in precautious differentiation
of naive T cells in presence of memory
Diesel and these are just few examples
though we do not I did not search today
and I haven't presented how how our T
cells like just by removing cd45 are a
positive cells results in in reaching
the responsiveness of entries and
specific T cells if it is by T Cell
interaction or secretion of inhibitory
component
we have done something understood we
have done and evaluated some of the
underlying mechanism to look into this
effects and um I really hope that we are
able to publish our paper soon so and
you'll be able to look into this more
details about the effects of our
education and potential mechanisms
underlying the effects of our expressing
subsets
and so despite of all the success and
despite all these um effects that we
observe with our entries and specific T
cells by City 45 higher education in our
approach I would like to mention some
some of our limitations and talk about
the limitations
um so as I mentioned before that we are
removing stem select memory which are
really known to be long label self-runic
memory cells and even and I did so that
our concern is diminished by long-term
Persistence of our evbsts in vitro and
in Vivo only the evaluation from
follow-up and data and present
evaluation will indeed tell us if we're
able to create an important product
and also our applic our applicability of
City Footwear depletion where we do
indeed remove TSC um is also limited by
the availability of clinical grade human
micro bits to own with cd45 area
positive cells and we cannot do so
without removing tscm there we could
potentially utilize a city 95-bit
selection which would go on to select
stem cell like memory cells Central
memory affect your memory and um
terminal differentiated memory cells we
however have not utilized or evaluated
cd95 bids in doing so and this is also
concerned Again by the lack of clinical
grid antibody to do so
additionally yes our approach is highly
highly applicable in generating virus
specific T cells and potentially tumor
entities in specific results which we
have not evaluated so far
but you do have to be upon takes some
concern in our strategies requiring
array positive or TSM for persistent
anti-tumor activity meaning that if your
cells of Interest are residing in are a
positive fraction then our strategism
might not give you the best result that
you would want to foreign specific
results and that would mostly be
particularly for tumor it is in specific
T cells or new antigen specific T cells
which are generating from third party
healthy donors where the cells of
Interest might reside in are a positive
fraction and depleting City photo value
positive might hinder the success of
etisal immune therapy
albeit with all his um limitations I
hope today I have um so new that we
indeed have established a highly
clinically feasible City fortified
depletion approach to enrich and is any
specific resource for our ebb specific
results which is also applicable as
generating virus specific T cells that
are specific to various virus and
potentially has applicability in other
immunotherapy
with this I would like to thank everyone
that has helped me with this project and
specifically my mentor Dr Rooney and
everyone that is involved in my grad
school and in our Center
CSR children hospital and I would also
like to thank miltonia again for this
opportunity to provide
thank you so much
thank you Dr Sharma for your time today
and your important research before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today I'd also like to thank
our sponsor miltony biotech for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until October 5th 2024. lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye